JAVIER RAMIEREZ: OK.
So yeah.
That's me.
That's my Twitter
account, in case
you want to ask
anything, or complain
about the low quality of
what I'm saying, or whatever.
Make fun of me.
It's quite easy, so
don't worry about that.
I'm going to tell how we
are using two Google tools--
BigQuery and Apps Scripts for
doing analytics at teowaki.
I'm not actually the
CEO of the company,
just one of the founders.
We don't have a CEO.
It's like, OK.
It's like, whatever.
So Yeah.
We have this two
people in the company.
We just launched this service
in public in February.
We have 500 users at the moment.
Trying to get more.
It's a startup.
You know.
It's not like yeah, it's
not this sort of startup.
Different kind of startup.
That's it.
So.
Yeah.
What we are doing is a service
for software developers
to communicate with each other.
So if you are a developer, or
you have a team of developers,
and you need to
exchange information
like interesting links,
documentation, gossip,
life hacks.
Sort of messages with
other developers.
You can just use teowaki.
Basically we have
groups of teams
in teowaki with
different people.
And also each person can be
in a lot of different teams
at the same time.
So you know, by
using this, you can
be up-to-date with
what's happening
across all your teams.
If you are like
working at your company
and also part of an
open source team.
If you are a developer
which is going to meetups,
or you are doing freelancing
for different clients,
or you still want to
be in touch with people
in your former
company, whatever.
You can be in touch with all
of them at the same time.
You can say get send
messages to all of them
or just to people in an area.
Share your mistakes,
server names, whatever.
Talk about code,
talk about the tools
you're using, or talk about how
you're organizing your service.
So that's the company.
Just a quick overview,
so you can understand
what we are doing and
what we want to measure.
This is the website so far.
So this is a website of
[INAUDIBLE] analytics.
We have Google analytics,
which are amazing.
We like to think we're using
analytics professionally,
because before
starting this company,
we've been doing some
work for 15 years.
And yeah, analytics are
amazing, because you
can have not only cool numbers,
but also visualizations.
Like for example, what are
analytics, out of the box.
Just put a script.
And it's going to give you like
visualizations like how people
are moving across your page.
So first they are
going to the homepage.
From here they are going to
the help page, login, whatever.
You can also bring
down and no, I
want to see these
only for the UK.
Because you were seeing before
all the other countries.
So analytics are
amazing, as we saw.
You can do like cool things.
Also we have a small company.
I told you already.
And I would not have
the time for being
like all day long, like,
what's in my numbers?
And saying, oh, I don't know.
I'm going to really think
about that real interesting way
of extracting
intelligence from my data.
So the good thing
about Google Analytics
is it's going to give you
automatically some alerts.
Like for example, hey,
we have more users.
We are having, I don't know,
more space views, whatever.
This was unexpected.
So that's for free.
You are getting a lot of
insight without doing anything,
because you don't have the time.
Or I don't have the money
for hiring another scientist.
If any scientists want to
work for free, that's cool.
But I don't know of any.
Analytics are amazing.
But there is a problem.
You can't always
use web analytics.
Because web analytics are
built for web applications.
So you have a web application.
You put the Javascript
code, everything's working.
If you have more
web applications,
you can also make it work.
But in teowaki,
we have a service
which is for
software developers.
We integrate with
satellite services.
Like, I don't know.
If a developer is putting
code into the system,
deploying a new virtual
into production,
found a new
[INAUDIBLE], whatever.
And you are using
different tools for that.
You are aggregating that
data also into teowaki.
And that data is not
coming from the web.
It's coming from
something called API.
And API dirty.
It looks like this.
This is our web page.
So we're getting information
from different places
which are not on the website.
Maybe you're thinking,
but I don't have API.
But still, you have a lot of
probably offline information.
Like if you an e-commerce,
and you are delivering goods
to someone.
If you want to know how
long is your delivery time.
If you're doing right or wrong.
You don't have that
on the website.
If you call center
and you are getting
calls from someone wanting
to cancel their account.
That's not on the website.
So there is a lot of information
that is out of the website,
and it's out of the
control of analytics.
But it's really important to
us knowing what's going on,
even if the information is
not coming to the website,
it's important for my business.
So we wanted to have a
solution in which we could
have analytics on all
that information that's
coming from other sources.
Since the first moment--
well this is teowaki.
So since the first
moment we thought
this was a Big Data problem.
First, because it sounds cool.
Big data is the new buzz word.
And second, because
actually we are
going to have lots of
data in the system.
We are tracking every
visit to the system,
we wouldn't have big data.
So since I'm assuming
not every one of you
understands what is big data.
Maybe yes, I can be wrong here.
But I didn't know
it until not so
long ago that it's
this definition, which
is like big data is when
your data is really too big.
Like much bigger than
the one you are used to.
Or when it moves too fast.
If you have too many things
coming at the same time.
Or when it's like really,
really weird to fit it
into your system.
So in our case, I told
you we have 500 users.
At the moment we already have
over 1,500,000 rows of data.
So 500 users, over
1,000,000 rows
of data in a month
and a half, so yeah,
the data we have
from the analytics
is much, much
bigger than the one
we have our system prepared for.
So we were thinking, OK.
We need to find a
big data solution.
So we can put a lot
of data in the system,
and then do something with it.
And we wanted to have--
this was like the wish list.
The system for having analytics
shouldn't be intrusive.
It shouldn't slow down
the user experience.
Second thing, we want
to have the history
and avoid any vendor lock-in.
If now it's iniquity.
But as I work for Google, maybe
a year from now, six months
from now, I find
a better solution.
I want to move out.
Because you know, I want to have
the best solution I can afford.
So it's a leap of
faith, basically.
So I live really cheap.
So you know, I want
to have all the data.
I don't want vendor lock-in.
And I want to have
interactive queries.
Meaning that every time I
want to have new information,
I don't want to write a
report, compute interface,
having to develop
the thing myself.
Or if I'm not a
developer, hire someone.
So I should have the capability
for running interactive queries
to the system.
It has to be cheap.
Because we have two people.
Not a big company.
If I have to choose between
paying for analytics
or paying for lunch,
lunch is going
to win almost all the time.
And it it's real time,
that would be amazing.
We don't need it, but
it would be amazing.
So it's like first problem.
You are going to have
millions of data.
Where are you going
to store data?
On a universal
store, or so having
a backup, and all those things.
So this service is quite easy.
There is something called
Google Cloud Storage.
If you are not
familiar with this,
maybe you're familiar with
something called Amazon S3.
They were coming out
with this anyway.
It's like cloud storage.
It's somewhere where
you put lots of files,
and it's like
really, really cheap.
In our case, it's storing
million and one half rows,
it's costing us like
zero comma zero, zero,
zero, zero something per month.
Which is OK for us.
We have that money.
It's like, we
don't have funding.
But we have savings.
So that's good for us.
So cloud storage.
That's why they say.
It was like the first things.
It's storing the data, it's
not storing anymore today.
It was a few years ago.
You need to have huge servers.
This was terribly expensive.
That's not a problem.
That's it.
Second things.
This is a problem today.
OK.
So you have millions of data.
Two million rows or whatever.
How are you going to run
queries over the data?
Because if you have been
around IT for a bit,
you know running a complex
query can take a while.
So I don't want my
queries to take a while.
I want them right now.
I mean in the next 10 seconds.
So how can I do that?
[INAUDIBLE]
There's some big data solutions.
This is like two
are not open source.
The others you have
to pay for that.
Something called Hadoop,
which is like something
for doing big data.
Cassandra, blah, blah--
they are too complex.
You need to start your
own servers or have
a [? farm-out ?] service on
the cloud, whatever that means.
And then you have to be
like putting it up and down.
If something is broken you
have to manage to fix it.
We are two people.
We don't have the time for this.
We actually know how
to use these tools.
It's just that we don't the
not enough time or money
for this to be cost effective.
Amazon Redshift is
hosted in the cloud.
It's more cost effective
than the others,
because if you have
like not really,
really billions of rows.
Because you just
pay for the use.
But the thins with
Amazon, you pay
for how long the
system is running.
So if I want to query
a system like now,
I just have the system, I input
the data, I run the queries,
and I stop it.
Because if I don't
stop the system,
I'm going to be paying
for the minutes.
Every minute it's
working, you have to pay.
You don't pay much, but you
have to be like, start it.
Stop it.
Now I want two servers.
Now I want 10 servers.
So it's better for us this way.
But still it's not good enough.
So we found this thing
called Google BigQuery.
And this was amazing for us.
Because Google BigQuery is
exactly what we're looking for.
It's like data
analytics as a service.
So this means you
put data there.
You put in the
data and it works.
I didn't do anything else.
It was like, oh, it sounds
like just the ticket for us.
And it was.
It's been for us OK.
It's based on something
called Dremel.
Dremel is an internal tool
that Google developed.
They were using it intensively
or a lot of things.
Like managing ad wars
and those things.
So that's internally
what they are using.
And it's designed for
petabytes of real-time data.
Petabytes of data
means something
that you totally don't have.
You have the [INAUDIBLE]
that [INAUDIBLE] to have.
That's really a blessing.
It is designed for having
double data, real-time.
That's quite cool.
Loading data is quite easy.
You send a file-- a text file.
Or JSON, if you are a
developer and you prefer JSON,
you send it from any
tool in the world.
You can convert to text file.
You send the text file there,
it's going to be stored.
And in the next few
seconds, you can already
get get data from there.
How many of you are familiar
with the concept of SQL?
Like the device is
SQL, or whatever.
Yeah.
A few of you.
OK.
SQL has been around
for 25 years.
Longer than some of you.
So the thing is, SQL is like a
standard language in which you
can basically access
to the databases.
On Big Data, now
its a trend that
you can already use
SQL with some tools
for querying your data.
So if I store data
on BigQuery, I
can do something
like give me the name
of all the users
ordered by date.
And it's going to give you
the name of the users by date.
It's quite easy to understand.
Or give me how many
users I have in total.
Or give me the
maximum date of users.
So for knowing which was
like the latest registration,
for example.
Or give me the
total of the orders
of it's user grouped by user.
So it's an easy enough language.
So you already know
SQL, you already
know how to use BigQuery.
And it has an extension
for analytical things
like percentiles, on variants,
and all these things.
If you're like a statistician
and you want to do more things,
they have some extensions.
But basically it's like SQL.
Like quite easy to use already.
If you have a developer on your
team, they know SQL already.
team and they don't know SQL,
you probably want to find
part of the developer
but until then I told you
So this is how it looks.
If you go to the
website of BigQuery,
they have also like an API.
If you like API's,
that's amazing.
I like them.
But if not, you have
the web console.
And yeah, you enter the
query, you click on Run,
and then you get the results.
How cool is that?
It's like, I'm not really
doing this as easy currently.
There's one thing.
You see that green
button on the right?
It's called validation
button, but to me it's
like the starter button.
Because in BigQuery, you're
going to pay for how many data
you are querying.
So before running
a query, you want
to be sure you're
not going to be
searching in too many tables.
The thing is if
you have like-- you
are storing the users,
their IP address, the email,
the last receipt, whatever.
And you only want to know
when was the last receipt,
you should only ask for
the last receipt column.
Because if you ask
for more columns,
you are going to pay much
for that particular query.
So the green button
there when you click on
that, it's going to tell you
A-- I'm going to go over-- I
don't know-- one
gigabyte of data.
And it's like, no, I prefer
to go only about half that.
So you can just
fine tune your query
before actually mounting it,
so it's going to be cheaper.
So you have the starter button
to the right, that's important.
You can do [INAUDIBLE].
Like for example, who
is my most active user?
Because segmentation is amazing.
If you can segment by people who
are coming on Saturday morning
from the US, that's cool.
But if you can segment by,
give me this particular user.
The one with the ID 105.
I know that's the user
I want to take care of.
Not because he's part
of this segment group.
No.
Because I sent a query
so I can actually
identify single
users using my API.
I have all the history.
I can see what a
single user has been
doing for the whole
life of the application.
Single users.
That's cool.
Because you can
really target people.
Imagine you have a problem, and
then you write a support email.
You can see the user
has been using the tool
again after that
support email or not.
So that's really cool.
You can really segment
the way you want.
Of course you can
segment by country
or whatever you want to do.
We are using it for many things.
Like for example, for
performance teams.
We are developers, so
we are querying the data
to see how people
are using it to see
if we can improve
our performance.
But basically,
depending on your data,
you can imagine creative
ways of using it.
This for example,
is one of my PPI's.
It's like how many users
you have per month.
So we like to know how many
users are using the too.
We want to compare
with the past month,
so we are sure the trend is OK.
So you know, writing something
which is not that difficult.
We are just getting how many
users are using the tool.
And if you want
to locate it, you
can get something a bit ugly.
This is not actually ours.
It's from people from BIT-Cup.
It's another software company.
You know, this query is
doing something like,
give me all the projects that
are being created every day.
And out of those
projects, give me
the projects that are
being watched at the moment
by most users.
So it's like
trending repositories
on a single query
over billions of rows.
These people have
over 8 million users.
So for billions of
rows, every day,
they are having this query
for the trend in repositories,
and sending it via email.
Which looks a bit weird,
buy if you think like, OK.
This is going to serve billions
of rows, 8 million users.
It's like sorted enough.
Still, I can see your faces now.
And they look like this.
It's like, what was that?
Exactly.
Because I don't want to be
writing these queries all
the time and figuring out.
Because I prefer Excel.
Oh sorry.
Google Express It.
Excel.
I prefer Google Express It.
So to me, data it's
much more convenient
if can see just
colors and numbers
and some fancy graphics.
This is a user sample.
This is users that have
been late in their account.
Maybe they are more or less.
So it's like, oh, so you
can export alphabetically
from this query to
Google Express It.
No.
You can't.
Sorry, you can't.
You're like, whoa!
What are you telling me?
But there's something called--
yeah, yeah, I know, I know.
I feel your pain now.
You can export to CSV,
which is close enough.
OK?
But here's something
called Apps Scripts,
which is also from Google.
And it's for free.
Totally for free.
And with Apps Script,
it's something,
it's like JavaScript, like a
smaller set of-- do any of you
know JavaScript?
You know more than you need.
Because it's like a
smaller set of JavaScript.
Apps Script is something that
lets you interact with most
of Google API's.
So is you want to interact with
Google Drive, with BigQuery,
with Google
Analytics, with Gmail,
almost all of the Google API's.
I will say [INAUDIBLE].
I'm not totally sure about that.
You can do that.
So what we have done.
What we have done
in the company,
is we have this script which
is running data from BigQuery,
then creating a spreadsheet
on Google Drive,
and then sending an email.
So every morning at 9:30 in
the morning, I get this email
with my [? KPI ?]
indicators, telling me OK,
this is how many
users for the month.
This is their usage, and
this is a link to the Express
It if you want to drill down the
data and do whatever you want.
Is it difficult?
You have to program a bit.
But it's quite
easy, I would say.
For example, Apps Scripts is
something that runs on the web.
You don't need to
install anything.
You just go to
Scripts, or google.com,
or something like that.
And then you start on your
project and that's it.
It's part of the Google Drive.
So what I'm doing here is,
OK I go to Google Drive,
I get the aps.folder.
I have a folder in Google Drive.
I'm creating an [INAUDIBLE]
with a date of today.
Then I'm just putting there the
new users I have per month that
are coming from BigQuery,
[INAUDIBLE] users,
and sending the email.
Sending an email-- oh sorry.
Sending an email.
This is what I have
in my apps.folder now.
It's like for every
day, I have Express It.
Which is the one I
showed you before.
Sending an email
is as easy as OK,
I want to send an email to this
person, copy to this person.
This is the subject.
This is the body.
This is the attachment.
And you are sending
an email like that.
So sending emails from
Apps Scripts is quite easy.
And this is what the
email looks like when
I get it in the morning.
OK.
This is your drive, and this
is your tool KPI at the moment.
So cool.
Every morning I'm
having this information.
I'm getting if from BigQuery.
Except it's weird like
the JavaScript here.
But basically, this is the
query I was talking to before.
The one I showed you before.
So you can write it on
the web on the console,
or just put it here.
So every day we're
running this thing,
we are getting the document,
and we're getting the email.
If you're going to
use BigQuery and you
want to have this
subscript yesterday.
I can access them for you.
So the only thing you
will need to change
is here you have to
pull your queries.
Here you have to pull
your user ID number, which
is on the internal, on
your Google account.
Here you have to
pull your email,
because you don't want
to send the analytics
to me, but to you.
But if you want to use
this, just ask me later,
I will set it.
That's cool.
One more thing.
This is real expensive, because
someone was speaking before
about BigQuery.
And he said something
about, it's quite cheap.
Cheaper than the others.
$20,000 per month.
I was like, $20,000 per month?
Come on!
So if you are quite big, it is
that cheap. $20,000 per month.
But for us, it's like this.
Cloud storage, you
pay like nothing.
In our case, it's
storing 1,000 ,000 rows.
It codes in dollars.
It codes this number.
I don't know how to
pronounce this number.
Like zero, zero, zero, zero, 92.
In pounds, it's like nothing.
And for BigQuery, which
is a bit more expensive.
BigQuery is more
expensive I have like, OK.
This is the price.
So I'm paying for
1,000,000 rows,
this amount of pounds per month.
And for storing, I'm paying
this amount per month.
So in total, this is what I'm
paying for having Big Data
analytics about
any data you want.
Because you can send there any
data you have in your company.
This is what I'm paying
for 8 million rows I have.
Actually this is wrong,
because just yesterday I
knew that the first hundred
gigabytes of queries
you do they're for free
on BigQuery every month.
But they just made this better.
The first terabyte is for free.
So this is going to be even
cheaper for next month.
So this is what it costs
to me to have the system.
And I can afford this.
So I have all the
goals that I wanted.
Non intrusive.
I have the history.
It's cheap.
It's real time if you want.
I don't need real
time, but it is.
And that's what I wanted to say.
If you know how to do things,
you can also do big things
and use Big Data, even if
as a startup, sometimes
you feel you are in underwear.
So thank you for that.
[APPLAUSE]